Andrew tatemate actually rot in jail
Tate's jail time was recently extended
to the end of February are you innocent
Mr Tate
are you confident you're going to be
released today
which means Tate is going to spend at
least two months in a freezing jail cell
even though there's no clear evidence
for the crimes they accuse them of but
it gets worse a few days ago the tape
Brothers appeared in court to fight for
early release the judge denied their
request but here's the thing taste the
tension for more than 30 days without
any charges is a human rights violation
but it seems like the Romanian
authorities don't care about that at all
in their eyes Angie Tate and his brother
are guilty until proven innocence the
judges also decided to ignore all the
women who were defending Tate claiming
that they have been brainwashed forget
about the facts whether you like or
dislike and you're interested forget
about the fact if they had said
something in those last two years they
might have upset you or hurt you forget
whether you agree or disagree with their
reviews forget about it all so what do
you think is Tay innocent or guilty
subscribe for the next part because